Tradutor: Maurício Kakuei Tanaka
Revisor: Leonardo Silva
Eu descobri
que eu gostava de poesia,
que eu escrevia poesia,
aos oito anos de idade.
Aquilo ali pra mim foi
uma descoberta realmente interna.
Eu escrevia pra mim,
não contava pra ninguém.
Mas me fazia bem.
Eu descobri que a poesia
era uma válvula de escape.
E ela me servia,
como se tivesse aberto
um universo paralelo pra mim.
Ela funcionava muito bem.
Eu fui conhecer um primeiro
sarau aos 18 anos.
Até então, eu praticamente não contava
pra ninguém que eu escrevia.
Eu achava que o que eu falava
não iria interessar às outras pessoas,
que a minha trajetória não seria
importante pra outras pessoas,
até conhecer os saraus na periferia,
até encontrar irmãs e irmãos que tinham
as mesmas inquietações que a minha,
até perceber que eu podia
trocar com as pessoas.
O que elas falavam pra mim me fortalecia,
e o que eu falava pra elas
também servia de fortaleza.
Eu, esse ano, vou completar
28 anos de idade.
Há dez anos,
eu estou nessa caminhada
literária independente.
Há quatro anos, eu formei,
junto com amigos e amigas,
um coletivo chamado "Poetas Ambulantes".
A nossa intenção é declamar
e distribuir as poesias
dentro dos transportes públicos da cidade.
"Mas vocês ganham
dinheiro pra fazer isso?"
Não, a gente ganha sorriso,
a gente ganha atenção,
a gente desperta a poesia
que tem dentro das pessoas
e que elas esquecem
que faz parte do nosso dia a dia.
Eu já consegui lançar um livro
independente em 2013,
e esse ano, em março, lancei meu segundo
livro, também de forma independente.
E é engraçado:
quanto mais independente a gente é,
mais a gente depende dos outros.
Mas tem sido bonito isso.
É importante ver que
as pessoas nos fortalecem,
e como esses movimentos criam conexões.
Eu jamais iria imaginar
que a poesia iria me levar tão longe,
que a poesia poderia me levar ao Felipe,
que a poesia poderia me trazer aqui.
No ano passado, eu participei de um evento
feminista chamado "Diversas", em BH.
A gente fez um encontro com mulheres
que estavam fazendo uma ocupação rural.
A gente foi lá, naquele
chão de terra batido,
encontrar as mulheres,
seus filhos,
e uma das coisas
que eu mais ouvi nesse encontro
foi
quantas vezes elas pensaram em desistir,
e aquilo ficou ecoando dentro de mim.
Eu não conseguia entender
por que mulheres com histórias
tão maravilhosas...
sim, de dificuldade, mas...
por que desistir?
Elas não sabiam o quanto estava
sendo importante pra mim,
uma menina, ouvir a história delas.
E eu saí de lá com aquilo
reverberando dentro de mim
e escrevi essa poesia:
"Não desiste, negra, não desiste!
Ainda que tentem lhe calar,
por mais que queiram esconder,
corre em tuas veias força ioruba axé
pra que possa prosseguir.
Eles precisam saber que a mulher negra
quer casa pra morar,
água pra beber, terra pra se alimentar;
que a mulher negra é ancestralidade
de imbês e atabaques, que ressoam dos pés;
que a mulher negra tem suas convicções,
suas imperfeições, como toda mulher.
Eu vejo que nós, negras meninas,
temos olhos de estrelas,
que, por vezes, se permitem constelar.
O problema é que, desde sempre,
nos tiraram a nobreza,
duvidaram das nossas ciências,
e quem antes atendia pelo pronome alteza
hoje trava lutas diárias
por sua sobrevivência.
É preciso lembrar de nossa raiz,
semente negra de força matriz,
que brota em riste,
mãos calejadas, corpos marcados, sim,
mas de quem ainda resiste.
E não desiste, negra, não desiste!
Mantenha sua fé onde lhe couber,
seja espírita, budista, do candomblé.
É teu desejo de mudança,
a magia que traz na tua dança
que vai lhe manter de pé.
É, você, mulher negra,
[que do] tratamento 'majestade' é digna,
livre que arma seus crespos
contra o sistema,
livre pra andar na rua
sem sofrer violência,
e que, se preciso for,
levanta a arma, sim,
mas antes,
antes luta com um poema.
E não desiste, negra, não desiste!
Por mais que tentem te oprimir,
e, acredite, eles não vão parar tão cedo,
quanto mais você se omitir,
menos sobre a sua história
estará escrevendo.
Quando olhar pra suas irmãs,
veja que todas somos o início,
mulheres negras,
desde os primórdios,
desde os princípios.
África, mãe de todas,
repare nos teus traços, indícios,
é no teu colo onde tudo principia.
Somos as herdeiras da mudança
de um novo ciclo.
E é por isso que eu digo:
que não desisto, que não desisto,
que não desisto".
Resistência sempre, irmãs.
Gratidão.
(Vivas) (Aplausos)